I have a very anxious dog this song
escalates A little bit
well
he doesn't like to be alone and when you
leave he loses his mind
he's broken out of every candle we
bought
oh yeah he tears wrath through them the
last one he left the door on our bed
like a complete yeah
what you cherish
oh he'll eat
knows what matters most to you yeah
did I mention he opens doors now
my dog is Jason Bourne is that
that's what you need for your brand new
TV are these your favorite shoes you
mean these that I chewed and I'm gonna
in the corner thank you
I just a in the corner go clean up
my mess
[Music]
[Applause]
only things have taken a weird turn like
early this morning I woke up with his
paw on my mouth and he was staring right
at me yeah
heart eye contact
he licked my face
[Music]
slow and firm without consent yeah are
we doing this now and I pick up your
[Music]
I'm my dog's prison I'm gonna
up your house yes I will yes I will and
I'm gonna pee on your couch yes I will
yes I will and I'm gonna bark at a black
eye
think that you're racist yeah you'll get
canceled
[Applause]